[Music]
my name is Claire Calvert I am a junior
here at Hillsdale College majoring in
art I've been given the honor of
introducing our speaker for tonight
Robert H lattice is a research professor
at George Mason University and an
adjective faculty member at the Reilly
Center for science technology and values
at the University of Notre Dame he
earned a PhD in material science from
the University of Notre Dame and is a
graduate of the national security
Fellows Program at Harvard University a
former Major General in the US Air Force
general lattice last active duty
assignment was at the National
Reconnaissance Office where he was
director of advanced systems and
technology and deputy director for
systems engineering he also served in
the US Army both in the infantry and as
commander of an army tactical nuclear
weapons unit a recipient of the National
Intelligence Distinguished Service Medal
and the Air Force Distinguished Service
Medal he is author of future war
preparing for the global battlefield
please join me in welcoming dr. Robert H
lattice well let me just start off by
thanking Hillsdale for inviting me to
this you really have a wonderful place
here it's marvelous
and this event is really outstanding
then looking at some of the previous
talks there so varied it's quite
interesting that the way you did that I
don't know if you did it on purpose or
by accident but this one will be also
different so as a scientist as well as a
career military officer I thought a good
bit about technology and its impact on
war but also about the ways in which we
use and care for our soldiers sailors
airmen and Marines military leaders have
a do
of care to teach our soldiers about the
tools they use how they use them and how
they adhere to strict standards of
ethics and professional behavior these
concerns are no less important in
high-tech war than they are in close
combat perhaps even more important as a
retired military officer with special
interest in both technology and military
ethics I have a specific concern and
that is as new weapons technologies make
soldiering more lethal our soldiers will
find it more difficult than ever to
behave ethically and abide by the
long-established conventions regarding
the rules of war there are important
ethical issues associated with our
aggressive embrace of advanced
technologies for war fighting with the
highly uncertain aspects of artificial
intelligence the pervasive use of cyber
techniques for military purposes and the
impact of automation on military
decision-making in command and control
as Richard Danzig the former Secretary
of the Navy has said the multinational
reliance on ever advancing technological
capabilities is like loading increasing
numbers of bullets into an increasing
number of revolvers held to the head of
humanity even if no one ever wants a gun
to go off discharges may occur one
nations inadvertent release of a
pathogen of computer virus or an
autonomous AI agent may have worldwide
effects perhaps catastrophic aliy
damaging unto itself and inadvertent act
may trigger other reactions for example
a computer exploit intended to harvest
intelligence might unexpectedly disrupt
or be thought to disable a critical part
of an electrical grid or a financial
institution thus provoking some kind of
catastrophic retaliation emerging
warfighter technology warfighting
technologies in general are moving so
fast and we are racing to
rate them so quickly I fear we're giving
insufficient thought the potential
downsides and unintended consequences
and to their possible ethical
implications the world made serious
moral ethical errors in chemical
biological and nuclear weapons we have
to ensure we don't make those errors
again there are several important things
to note about technology and war first
technology and war have always been
intertwined I can give you numerous
examples
second we're seduced by and often
addicted to technology that iPhone you
have in your hand
third new technologies will dramatically
change conflict as we know it and fourth
new technologies will challenge soldiers
ethically rapid technology growth itself
poses an ethical challenge in the year
2000 Stuart brand wrote in Time magazine
that change that is too rapid that can
be deep deeply divisive if only an elite
can keep up the rest of us will go grow
increasingly mystified about how the
world works and what happens people just
give up giving up is bad enough in the
commercial and civilian realm we really
should have some kind of understanding
of the tools we use every day but giving
up is a very bad a really awful idea
when it comes to weapons and war where
lives are at stake
by definition there are in fact
downsides as well as upsides to
technology innovation some are clearly
good others are clearly bad some are
ambiguous pesticides kill parasites but
they pollute the water supply
antibiotics are wonderful but resistance
from their overuse kills thousands every
year new surveillance technologies may
increase workplace productivity but they
leave people concerned about privacy and
civil liberties and as we've discussed
with Professor Rubin last night who
knows what will be the long-term effects
of our new modes
communication in recent years war has
morphed into something that we can
scarcely recognize and future conflicts
will be fought using innovative and
unusual weapons many of which will be
available to far more people who are far
less skilled in their use in 1999 in a
document entitled unrestricted warfare
two Colonels predicted that soldiers
would be increasingly computer hackers
financed ears drug smugglers agents of
private corporations as well as military
members and that their weapons would
include not only airplanes cannons
poison gas bombs and biochemical agents
but also computer viruses net browsers
and financial derivative tools their
predictions repression tomorrow's Wars
will be very different still heavily
dependent on information superiority
weapons will employ such new
technologies as artificial intelligence
neuroscience and cyber none of which we
yet or may ever fully understand the
effects of Technology and vance Minh in
these areas are far more difficult to
predict and possibly to control than for
conventional weapons which are more
deterministic in their behavior the
convergence of all these new
technologies opens up even more
concerned machines increasingly
employing artificial intelligence we'll
watch for us they will think for us and
they will fight for us some of the
myriad uses of artificial intelligence
in the military include non weapons
perks purposes such as simulation and
training threat monitoring and
situational awareness information
processing battlefield healthcare and
logistics and transportation these are
tasks which are amenable to machine
learning and will likely have large
amounts of relatively stable data on
which to rely they seem to be tasked
which could be done well by such systems
and could be tested against years of
think of how great it would be if
soldiers wounded on the battlefield
could benefit from debt decades of
combat injury and treatment data better
yet if artificial intelligence systems
could ensure that the troops never
lacked for their necessary resources or
better still if autonomous vehicles
could replace human drivers than convoys
so vulnerable to roadside bombs on the
weapons in combat site important tasks
such as target recognition cyber warfare
and actual weapons or potential and
problematic uses of AI during the past
administration the DoD referred to its
strategy for military superiority in
terms of the third offset Deputy
Secretary of Defense described that
strategy as including autonomous
learning systems human-machine
collaborations and network enabled
semi-autonomous technology a mouthful
the currently the DoD includes among its
basic research interests quantum
information science we heard of that
today cognitive neuroscience human
behavior modeling artificial
intelligence cyber warfare command and
control space offense and defense
missile defense and hypersonics
hypersonic missiles and aircraft which
travel is speeds from 5 to 20 times the
speed of sound like high-powered lasers
and computer attacks will increasingly
strain the capability of human operators
to keep up there will be very short
timelines
creating greater dependence on machines
and artificial intelligence for
decision-making we must ask ourselves if
we are ready to see this much control
unmanned aerial terrestrial and naval
systems with new potentially autonomous
and lethal capabilities are now being
developed and have been developed and
can be controlled by our official
intelligence robots and autonomous
systems allow us to reduce the risk to
our warfighters that's good
but there are numerous and strong
objections to give
autonomous systems lethal capability
underlying many of the concerns are a
skepticism that any computer program
could satisfy ethical and legal
principles and a Content belief that it
is categorically wrong to take the human
moral agent out of a firing decision
since 2012 DoD policy has been that the
military will not employ completely
autonomous lethal systems however
notwithstanding the stated policy the
pressure to employ lethal autonomy will
be great while we may never make a
deliberate decision to employ lethal
autonomous systems the decision will be
one of omission not commissioned with
our use of these systems happening
slowly and incrementally as the speed
and demands of combat increase other
issues surrounding the research and
potential employment of autonomous
systems especially lethal weapons our
complexity and unpredictability these
systems contain millions of lines of
computer code and computer programs even
AI programs inevitably contain errors
some of these may be fatal
both in a computer sense and in a real
sense also taking humans out of the
decision process undermines the
possibility of holding anyone
accountable a key element of military
operations in military ethos and what
happens if non rational actors get their
hands on these systems because the
speeds with which cyber war would be
conducted the difficulty of
distinguishing between exploitation and
attack is great and dangerous
misperceptions can result operations at
computer speeds in such a complex sphere
of battle taxes through the capabilities
of our highly-trained cyber soldiers not
to mention the intellectual capabilities
of our decision makers such as they are
again in this domain as with many
weapons systems artificial intelligence
will play an outsized role
many current AI systems are excellent
for what they do but they fail miserably
they're brittle when they are asked to
do something else
nevertheless the growing power of more
narrowly focused AI algorithms like
Netflix and Amazon has sparked a wave of
commercial interest what an
understatement according to the
Congressional Research Service US
technology companies invested an
estimated twenty to thirty billion
dollars in 2016 which will probably grow
as high as a hundred and twenty six
billion by 2025 DoD whose needs for AI
include all of those things I have just
mentioned is investing billions in AI
the Pentagon spent two and a half
billion in 2017 on artificial
intelligence and every military service
is working to fund autonomous systems
experts have estimated that the
artificial intelligence expenditure in
the global military market is projected
to grow from six billion in 2017 to 18
billion in 2025 in Washington the
military services and agencies of the
intelligence community cannot go fast
enough in trying to incorporate machine
learning and AI it seems to me that AI
is the technology that is consuming the
government although it has potential for
significant military advantages it may
also have significant challenges while
the technology can facilitate autonomous
operations lead to more informed
decision-making and increase the speed
and scale of military action it is also
unpredictable and vulnerable to unique
forms of manipulation anathema to
military planners researchers are still
at a loss about how to adequately test
these systems and assure that they can
be trusted to give correct answers
potential AI problems are their
inability to explain their decisions and
their vulnerability to computer hacking
as for unpredictability recent reporting
on a google deepmind AI system designed
to play a game
we're in it collected items noted that
as the system began losing it developed
an unexpected aggression employing its
laser weapons against its opponent
today's AI systems suffer from an
inability to detect flawed data that
causes a machine learning system to make
mistakes and an unusually high
susceptibility to malicious inputs or
spoofing these vulnerabilities are
distinct from traditional software
vulnerabilities and demonstrate that
while AI systems can exceed performance
of the human in many ways they can also
fail in ways that a human never would as
Aarthi Prabhakar the former director of
the Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency said the problem is that when
it's wrong it's wrong in ways that no
human would ever be wrong and if
military units rushed to feel the
technology without first understanding
these issues they may field systems that
have minimal risk individually but
increase the danger of catastrophe as
errors are compounded by each new
addition to the inventory such
luminaries as Bill Gates Elon Musk
whatever you think of him and the late
Stephen Hawking have sounded alarm bells
over the continuing push for an Mart of
artificial intelligence musk in a phrase
similar to that used during the
development of nuclear weapons known as
tickling the dragon has famously
referred to the use of AI as summoning
the demon summoning the demon indeed in
a speech last year Russian President
Vladimir Putin said in a bit of
hyperbole artificial intelligence is the
future not only for Russia but for all
of humankind whoever becomes the leader
in this sphere will become the ruler of
the world that should give us pause not
necessarily or just because of who said
it but because he believes it to be true
so what will the battlefield of the
future look like for sure it will be
uncertain chaotic noisy and
and scary so what's new in addition to
regular soldiers it will be populated
with large numbers of augmented humans
of some form likely using
performance-enhancing pharmaceuticals of
various sorts and very possible with
implanted electronics or cyber physical
systems decision-making will be highly
automated and automated processes will
power the tools of war cognitive
modeling of the opponent employing AI
will be used to anticipate in enemy
actions before they can decide and make
them in addition to classical combat
techniques military forces will make
great use of something called micro
targeting wherein individuals
individuals will be targeted based on
detailed signatures collected from a
vast array of sensors and databases
units and individual weapons will
exhibit large-scale self-organization
and collective decision-making to
increase the lethality of the unit
robots will be ubiquitous operating in
teams with human beings and on their own
either singly or more likely in swarms
dynamic hacking and spoofing will be
rampant with intense information and
psychological operations and the use of
misinformation as a weapon fake news on
the battlefield there will be a dense
environment of electromagnetic signals
for both communications against
communications and possibly for
anti-personnel purposes directed-energy
weapons including lasers and microwaves
will be employed against both human and
material war as we know it will be
increasingly about information
superiority with adversaries attempting
to destroy one another's ability to
sense and decide and then act recently
dr. Alexander caught the US Army's chief
of network science division of the Army
Research Laboratory described the future
battlefield electronic signal
environment as primordial soup
neuroscience technologies are helping
wounded soldiers recover from traumatic
brain and other injuries rapid advances
have been made in the neural control of
prosthetics and in the broader general
area of brain machine interface and
research is going on into the use of
chip implants to restore brain function
DARPA has shown that it is possible to
download signals from some specific
brain activity onto an implanted chip
and subsequently if brain function is
destroyed by some means it can be
restored by redownload the contents of
the chip back into the brain sounds
weird
neuroscience raises numerical numerical
numerous ethical issues despite
miraculous breakthroughs such as the
development of mind controlled
prosthetics researchers now know enough
about the function of neurons and their
signaling to create mind controlled
prosthetic limbs with artificially
induced feeling in which an external
signal is sent back into the brain DARPA
is also making progress in mapping the
neural architecture of pathologies such
as schizophrenia they are now able in a
sense to read the minds of individuals
of course should be quick to point out
DARPA researchers have pointed out to me
that what is meant by the brain is
fraught with ambiguity by the mind be
that as it may if we can read thoughts
whatever that means it also stands to
reason that we can write them once the
structure of thoughts and emotions are
understood it is perfectly conceivable
that they could be inserted into the
brain from an external source so
neurological enhancement raised deep
ethical questions and concerns about
compromised character justice and
coercion what effects do neurological
enhancements have on human essence or
human moral agency what will be the
effect on personal autonomy and
we will concerning future
decision-making and command and control
in 2003 an Army War College papal paper
titled crack in the foundation
then Lieutenant Colonel HR McMaster
recently of National Security Council
spoke on the new theories of war that
had taken on names evoking a sense of
control such terms as metric
network-centric warfare third wave
warfare an information age war minimize
the concepts of imagination and human
initiative and placed decision-making in
the realm of advanced computers and
networks command and control was
grounded in the assumption that
technology would provide certainty it
would as Admiral Bill Owens opined at
the time lifted the fog of war
near-perfect information was to make
possible precise application of force
from great distances which would in turn
reduce the risk of to US forces and
minimize collateral damage here we are
almost two decades later sound familiar
the ability of the u.s. to successfully
implement its strategy or whatever it
chooses to call it now will depend on
its innovative use of information
technologies artificial intelligence
autonomous systems robotics and cyber
techniques the term information at
technology of course encompasses a range
of topics including the internet
high-performance computing algorithms
data collection storage data
transmission data mining and analysis
and the Internet of Things putting
sensors on everything and tying them to
the Internet we heard some about this
this afternoon unsurprisingly the
military has its own Internet of Things
almost everything including conventional
bombs and nuclear weapons soldier
communications and satellites simple
vehicles and advanced armor systems
lasers and navigation systems all depend
on computers and their components many
even have their own URLs one writer
recently referred to the military as one
giant armed nervous system calling to
mind the cephalopod neural structure a
surprisingly intelligent group of
creatures with large brains and
distributed decision centers and their
appendages think of the octopus this
seems to be an apt analogy with our
distributed command and control regime
where every appendage is equipped with
sophisticated sensors and highly
automated decision support systems
artificial intelligence is again being
touted as a technology which will
revolutionize command and control and
military decision-making and how much
should decision makers depend on these
systems to give advice to humans to make
so called time critical decisions how
can we assure trust that these systems
are not biased and are telling us the
correct things on battlefields of the
past killing was intentional and tensely
personal in the future the automated
nature of combat the artificial
enhancements of its soldiers and the
speed and distances involved will all
threaten to undermine the Warrior Ethos
increasingly warfare will exceed the
capabilities of the human senses to
collect and process data DoD policy on
autonomy and weapon system says a human
will always be part of the decision
process but gradually perhaps
imperceptibly automated systems will
function so much more efficiently than
humans that the humans will become mere
bystanders the soldier will become the
slowest element in the engagement or
will simply become irrelevant adherence
to the rules of war will become less
relevant as well console' Jers under the
influence of behavior modifying drugs or
electronics be held to account for their
actions if the soldier is using drugs or
electronics to reduce his fear what's
the role of freewill - sold
who fears nothing unnecessarily place
himself his unit or innocent bystanders
at risk and what about the impact of
memory altering drugs on the soldiers
sense of guilt which might be important
in laws of war decisions about
unnecessary and superfluous suffering so
on the subject of ethics the US
Department has long been known for its
support of technology innovation who is
now debating the appropriateness of new
weapons technologies and the ethical
considerations laws of armed conflict
and international humanitarian laws
remain important in a new age of war and
weapons it is even more important to
analyze how the changes affect and are
affected by the age-old concepts of
military necessity discrimination of
combatants from non-combatants
proportionality and the avoidance of
unnecessary suffering for example on
unnecessary suffering troops in contact
on the battlefield
have a great sense for noticing the
wavering determination of an enemy it is
not at all clear that an automated AI
based systems could make an empathetic
decision to not press an attack or will
a robot be willing to sacrifice itself
for a human can a robot or an AI system
be altruistic should a human be asked to
protect a robot at the cost of his or
her life I have spoken with soldiers who
served multiple combat tours in Iraq and
Afghanistan and with the military
chaplains whose job it was to provide
pastoral support and care for the
soldier's Souls not long ago one of
those army chaplains discussed with me
the difficulties he faced in caring for
the soldiers in his unit which had
experienced an unusually large numbers
of soldiers killed or wounded the unit
commander had never discussed or
emphasized the laws of armed conflict or
tried to explain any rationale for what
the unit was tasked to do and the
importance of such concepts as
protecting the innocent or using only
the men
necessary amount of force many of the
soldiers had engaged in horrific battles
in which numerous civilians were killed
and their comrades died for seemingly no
reason
the chaplain described to me his daily
challenges of offering hope and pastoral
care to scores of soldiers
it was his strongly held belief that the
teaching of concepts of Just War theory
in advance with this recognition of the
legitimacy of war and the emphasis on
proper behavior would serve first as a
governor on unrestrained violence so
often generated in combat and second to
soften or mitigate the damage the war
dead to their souls he also believed
that morally neutral codes of being that
ignored ethics and couched combat
operations in more utilitarian terms
exacerbate improper behavior and caused
more moral injuries as well as frustrate
their treatment popes have often cited
and needed a need for the Catholic
Church while hewing to its core values
to adapt to living in the present the
present is and the future will be very
dangerous and violent this is not merely
a belief folks but a fact of life Syria
Yemen Boko Haram Yas T's rangas Isis al
Qaeda and scores of horrific brutal
groups and activities out there attest
to the dangerous world in which millions
of people live maybe billions add to
these the accelerating introduction of
new technologies in the desire of many
countries to gain ballistic missiles and
nuclear weapons and you have a toxic and
volatile combination in the face of such
brutal realities it is absolutely
essential for religious leaders
everywhere of all denominations to
actively push the age-old concepts and
moral traditions of restraint finally on
speed
the current national defense strategy
focuses heavily on military power and
specifically calls for large increases
in investments in the technologies I've
mentioned the defense budget now
totaling almost three-quarters of a
trillion dollars per year calls for
additional civilians to be spent on
artificial intelligence and autonomy
many of the senior people and DoD and
Congress demand u.s. superiority and
artificial intelligence and don't have a
clue what it is or what it can do they
only know we need some of it
they are mostly silent on any discussion
of the broader implications of its use
the danger is now more than ever because
of the speed of technology development
that we tend to rush into the use of
technologies the 20th century theologian
Reinhold Niebuhr in his 1952 work the
irony of American history said that
American military power created the
temptation to become impatient and
defiant in the slow and sometimes
contradictory processes of history the
development speed of new and emerging
technologies is even more antithetical
and incongruent with Nibiru's slow and
contradictory processes in discussing
cyber capabilities author Lucas callow
noted in his book the virtual weapon
that in our era of rapid technological
change threats and opportunities arising
from a new class of weapons produced
pressure to act before the laborious
process of strategic adoption concludes
I fear patience is in short supply these
days one of my colleagues a former CIA
operative spy discussing the change in
our collective national security
behavior and the behavior of his former
organization has said that since the
events of September the 11th 2001 reason
and balance have become orphans in 1968
the foreign policy association in New
York sponsored a conference asking the
attendee
to gays 50 years into the future as one
might expect the conferees got some
things right and quite a few things
wrong but one attendee was unfortunately
probably the most correct when he said
it is much too optimistic to assume that
the technologies we provide to
governments would entail their ability
to use them wisely he noted correctly
that applying technologies like all
human efforts bears bittersweet fruits
sadly I do not see any appetite among
the nations of the world or within our
own government for slowing down the rush
to new technologies or war or even
considering limitations on their
proliferation some of you may know that
45 years ago scientists from around the
world meeting at Asilomar in California
agreed to a voluntary moratorium on some
types of recombinant DNA research in the
present day we have scientists defying
request for constraint and publishing
details of how they were able to
weaponize a deadly strain of bird flu
and nations rushing at breakneck speed
to incorporate new technologies like AI
with not a word about diplomacy to slow
down such a destructive arms race in
answering the question of what the 2068
battlefield would look like it is
tempting to echo that attendee from the
New York conference absent some dramatic
unforeseen and unlikely change in
American political behavior it will
likely be littered with bittersweet
fruits we are better than that
and I think we can do better we can tap
the brakes even if only slightly on
technology development and deployment
and ask probing questions of our
researchers and weapons developers and
we can take a leadership role and engage
other nations peer adversaries and
developing nations alike to consider
international agreements limiting and
controlling some weapons applications to
include and perhaps especially
artificial intelligence
but time is short and we have to start
now thank you
[Applause]
to sign copies of his book future war
preparing for the new global battlefield
immediately following the lecture we now
have time for a few questions please
raise your hand and wait for a
microphone to be brought to you I was
wondering if you're gonna talk so much
about all of the countries throughout
the world getting this new technology
and using it for war and they're
advancing really quickly and it's gonna
make our current tech obsolete
isn't there an imperative for us to at
least research at the same clip so that
we can defend our people if not be able
to fight them and win that's a great
question thank you and a question I get
all the time
you will notice maybe I hope I did say
it I never said anything about not doing
the research we yes we absolutely have
to research all of the things that
everyone else is doing and that's what
DARPA does a very good job the what I'm
suggesting is that before we rush to put
these things into weapons we consider
the implications of those things and I
suspect the next question will be why
should we be ethical if they're not
ethical but I won't go there so hello
thank you for your talk listening to you
discusses anything a lot of but the
situation between Lee and grant the
civil war where you had leave fighting
the gentleman's war and you had grant
coming with Napoleonic understanding of
war which when every war was the man's
war as we have things such as Sherman's
march and it made me wonder as a
religious leaders you said we need to
call for restraint
what does restraint look like morally
say someone is now fighting on a
different playing field how are we say
if we're taking lead Lee's stance how
are we supposed to respond to the grant
of AI I'm not sure I understood the
connection
ái with the question but it was actually
the question I was anticipating tell me
if this is correct but I don't think
that our moral behavior and the moral
behavior are of our enemies have
anything to do with one another at all
our moral frameworks should be our moral
frameworks and if an enemy decides they
want to engage in brutal and
reprehensible behavior it doesn't follow
that we should engage in brutal and
reprehensible behavior again I wasn't
sure of the connection with the AI so
elaborate on that ask your question in
light of all the developments of machine
learning and autonomous systems in
warfare how is military education
changed in light of that so for like new
soldiers and new cadets what are they
learning in light of this well the
military really is not all that
different from any other organization or
company that that hires young people the
military schools have to keep up with
the times so you can go to any of the
u.s. military academies at West Point or
Annapolis or the Air Force Academy and
find cyber programs you find them
teaching AI there are a lot of computer
hackers and geeks out there that weren't
there when I went to school that many
years ago so you know we follow the
trends like everyone else the difference
is that we attempt we do a really good
job in the in the military academies a
pretty good job with our soldiers we
attempt to inculcate in them what we
call the Warrior Ethos the military
ethos and that is something different so
it is up to the soldiers and the
officers to try to put those two things
together but you know we follow the
trends like everybody else
I was wondering which area of computers
seem to you most most valuable in the
future of war whether that would be
cyber attack or on the other hand more
computer vision neural network type work
and artificial intelligence
what's the most valuable route I'm
looking into going into this what what
kind of a path do you see forward in the
military what what aspect to focus on do
you think should be focused on by DARPA
well let me answer that a different way
because I certainly don't want to be
advising you on your career I will tell
you the area if it wasn't obvious from
my remarks the area that I think is
probably the most exciting and has the
most challenge and that's the area of
neuroscience being able to understand
the brain and the way in which we do and
modify the brain in which we do in ways
in which we can is is really exciting
probably to your your specific question
I would hazard that using artificial
intelligence for target recognition and
categorization is probably one of the
most important for military operations
for a presentation that was as scary as
I thought it might be okay you said
early in your presentation two words
that Stan stood out and they were
unintended consequences and I'm
wondering if we have any group or
individual who is looking into the
possibility of those things wondering
how to counteract them and then having a
bridge of communication to our
decision-makers about them so it's a
good question and one of the reasons
that I've got involved in this topic
several years ago
teaching at Notre Dame was what I saw as
a complete lack of that I didn't see
anybody and I was in the community and
research and development I didn't see
anybody doing those kind of studies I'm
happy to say that over the last several
years more people like myself
particularly a lot of academics and a
number of senior military not civilian
but senior military officers have come
to the fore and talked about the
importance of doing what you described
one example is just getting ready to
retire but the the vice chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff General Paul Silva
has been very vocal about doing those
kind of analyses so it's happening not
happen uh as you noted from my remarks
but I'll take whatever I can get it's
freshman here at Hillsdale thank you for
your lecture and back my question for
you is regarding civilian deaths is
there any way that artificial
intelligence could better distinguish
between soldiers and civilians by
tapping into databases and being able to
have a more accurate picture of who this
enemy is is it a soldier or is it as
that's an excellent question
it would obviously depend on the
battlefield it would depend on what kind
of sensors we had available to us if it
were just optical sensors probably not
if our infrared sensors
there are even ways now of finding
people's fingerprints at a distance
determining their heartbeat so if we
knew data about them we might be able to
tell this is a child not a small adult
so yes artificial intelligence can can
deal with data much much faster than a
human can but I still go back to my
premise that at the end of the day it's
the human that has to pull the trigger
not the machine so the answer to
question is yes hello sir my name is
Frank Vitali I'm a freshman here at
Hillsdale and my question is kind of
twofold first you mentioned
performance-enhancing drugs in their use
in the military and I was wondering
first if those kinds of
performance-enhancing drugs have been
used in more cyberwarrior type
applications like Cyber Command or or
organizations like that and if further
use of those was encouraged by the
military if that would lead to further
other technologies of human enhancing
like transhumanist type technologies so
I mentioned performance-enhancing drugs
and I can actually point you to army
documents which posit a soldier of the
future twenty thirty in which they
talked about very openly about giving
soldiers performance hands and drugs to
my knowledge the only group of military
people who use so-called performance
enhancing enhancing drugs are pilots who
have to fly long missions they take the
form of amphetamine not meth obviously
but an in form of in fetta mean to keep
them awake
I do not know if there is any legal or
sanctioned use of any kind of
performance-enhancing drugs and other
organizations like Cyber Command it
doesn't mean the hacker types won't take
ritalin and do it on their own but not
officially hello thank you for coming
and talking tonight my name is Leo SH
leader on mr. Rubin last night talked
about how far more of all of our
information is transmitted over the
internet nowadays than even a decade ago
and some of that information could be
potentially a threat to national
security right terrorists can use social
media networks and as the government you
have an incentive to break through you
know privacy protections on messaging
services and things like that on but as
the government worried you draw the line
between national security priorities and
then personal rights to privacy that's a
complex question it might take longer so
what I need to tell you is that the US
intelligence agencies by law and by
action are very very careful about
separating us persons data from foreign
persons data they make mistakes they've
made mistakes in the past but they're
they're very much attuned to that
question so the premise of you know when
do you break through that you only break
through that with with the full
knowledge of the courts and and it's not
done on a very regular basis but to your
to the earlier point about so much data
being out there yes it is very dangerous
so anybody in here who ever had or will
have a security clearance should know
that the Chinese stole the entire
database that was owned by the federal
government of everybody who had security
clearances so they probably know more
about me that I know more about me
so yeah that's really important data and
and we have only ourselves to blame we
have only ourselves to blame because
we've known about these vulnerabilities
for a long time and we haven't fixed
them hi thank you very much for your
speech
I'm Brian I'm a junior here at Hillsdale
College I was wondering you mentioned
that those who possess these innovations
in artificial intelligence computer
programs although these new
technological weapons are those that are
going to rule the world do you think
that as private corporations become
better and better at developing these
technologies you mentioned Google made
an artificial intelligence pot that
basically weaponized itself do you think
that the US government in the US
military will sort of lose potentially
their monopoly over these kinds of
weapons and that private companies will
eventually become as dangerous and as
much of a threat as another nation and
kind of lead to a sort of anarchy within
our own country so let me just be clear
I didn't say it Vladimir Putin said it I
kind of agree with him but not quite as
far as your the premise that that
companies are going to be taking over
and the government is going to be ceding
the responsibility to private
corporations in many ways we've already
done that companies the US government
and particularly the Defense Department
could not operate without its private
industry even so far at least in the
Iraq war they had civilians fighting I
think at the end of the day decisions
will always rest with the government
with the military now how you police
that is another question but so I don't
know I don't think that we will
basically have mercenary forces fighting
our Wars for us
sorry I have another question it's
honestly very similar that last one but
I was wondering as to connect the
distinction between civilian and Armed
Services becomes I feel like it's going
less and less as AI becomes more a part
of the human body the distinction
between civilian and soldier how are we
going to be able to tell that in the
future will there just be people well
they're not even be a distinction
between army and civilian I actually
don't understand that question there
will always be if you're in the military
you will know you're in the military and
others will know again what I don't
quite get is the connection to AI so I'm
sorry perhaps we can talk afterwards and
I can expand a little bit we have a
question to the speakers left
hello sir I'm Jacob Ladd we had a
speaker earlier mention getting first
two technologies in is incredibly
important and you mentioned how private
corporations are now developing
technology how can we keep this
technology in American hands without say
the Chinese government coming in and
taking all our files like they did
earlier so if I understand the question
is how you can keep it in American hands
well you can to be fair both Russia and
China particularly China if they're not
on par with us yet they will be very
soon they're putting 10 to 20 times more
maybe a hundred times more money into a
and we are so we're rapidly falling
behind Russia they don't quite have the
budget they are very very focused on on
confronting the US and all of these
technologies so we are no longer we
still are but we might not be ahead for
very long so keeping it out of the hand
and particularly it's in particularly
important to understand that these are
dual use technologies it's not like
nuclear weapons you can only use a
nuclear weapon for one thing these are
dual use technologies companies
worldwide companies global companies are
selling this stuff all over the world
keeping it out of anybody's hands the
only thing that I have recommended is
that we take a very hard look at the
application to warfare to weapons and
then try our best to negotiate
non-proliferation agreements that would
be the only way that I could think of to
keep it out of the hands of some of
those brutal groups that I mentioned
hello my name is Erin record I'm a
sophomore here I was wondering if you
would consider the development of
quantum computing capabilities to be
important for us cyber defenses
specifically in regards to the threat to
encryption systems that quantum
computing poses the question is do I
consider it important I can consider it
absolutely essential and I think the
talk today earlier did a really great
job of describing why that is but what
gets lost a lot of the times in the
discussion of quantum computing is that
there are some really cool things that
we can do with quantum physics besides
just computing so quantum sensing is one
that the military will have a great use
for and so yes and yes
we have time for one more question hi my
name is Hannah I'm a freshman here and I
was wondering you mentioned with AI and
the development that it would be both
like more precise but we also see it
with a lot more power so I was wondering
should we expect it to be like more
clean with less collateral damage or
should we expect it to be more powerful
in broad spec
in affecting more areas of our lives
like with messing with finances and
things like that should we expect it to
be more clean and precise with less
collateral damage around it or should we
expect it to be more widespread and
affecting different areas of our lives
like also going to messin with the
financial market and stuff like that
there are two questions there one is AI
is going to clearly affect all areas of
our life so it will depend on the
applications is it in terms of
collateral damage let me take that
question I think AI will probably be
extraordinarily helpful in limiting the
amount of collateral damage when used in
a proper way with weapons that have been
fired intentionally by human beings they
will do a good job they will do a great
job of kind of to the question about
targeting of identifying the proper
targets so and our ability to reduce
collateral damage by the way has greatly
increased over over time throughout time
we've done a really marvelous job so
yeah I think it'll help a lot
thank you